67 years. Three dozen movies. The
"Godzilla" franchise has had some
of the highest highs and lowest
lows in monster cinema history.
Keep watching to know which movies to
include in your next "Godzilla" marathon.
The worst of the worst is undoubtedly "Godzilla" –
not the original, but the American-made mess that
somehow made it into theaters in 1998. Director
Roland Emmerich's take on the classic kaiju tried
really hard to do some cool stuff with a unique
story and modern special effects, but laughable
CGI prevented it from having the punch producers
had hoped for. This version of Godzilla is barely
seen as it hides among buildings in New York —
because if there's anything Godzilla is known for,
it's hiding. That, and squeezing
through subway tunnels for some reason.
The closest thing the film has to a
saving grace is Matthew Broderick,
but even Ferris Bueller himself can't save
this movie from being a complete blunder.
Most fans would agree that the 1998 "Godzilla" has
had a negative impact on the franchise as a whole.
"Aw damn, uh, that is a negative impact,
I repeat, that is a negative impact."
They gave it their best shot, but Netflix
definitely missed the mark when they put out their
run of animated Godzilla movies. "Godzilla: Planet
of the Monsters," "Godzilla: City on the Edge of
Battle," and "Godzilla: The Planet Eater" aren't
as outrageously out-of-place in the Godzilla
canon as the 1998 film, but they're certainly not
quite outstanding enough to earn individual spots
on this list. This trilogy tries desperately
to compensate for a lack of compelling story
with vibrant animation, but the drama just isn't
there thanks to a lack of memorable characters.
This series gives a look at a post-apocalyptic
future Earth where humans have traveled into
space to escape Godzilla and other monsters'
continuous destruction. The concept is compelling
and could have made for a fantastic
new take on the Godzilla mythos,
but the execution doesn't
exactly stick the landing.
"Godzilla vs. Megaguirus" is another example of a
film that attempted to do something unique within
the Godzilla universe, but came out lukewarm at
best. Unlike the hulking beasts that Godzilla
is typically known for fighting, the Meganulons
featured in this entry in the Millennium series
are more like a swarm of annoying mosquitos. It's
only at the end of the movie, when Godzilla faces
off with the Meganulon queen Megaguirus,
that things actually start to get exciting.
The plot is mediocre at best,
reworking the Millennium-era Godzilla
into its own being while somehow
managing to stay disconnected from
every film that came before it. Add that to the
infamously bad acting from the human characters,
and you get one of many misguided attempts
to further the franchise after the Y2K scare.
Most viewers would agree that "Godzilla's
Revenge," also known as "All Monsters Attack,"
isn't the worst of films, but it's a tedious
watch and among the most skippable entries
in the franchise. "Godzilla's Revenge" was
geared toward small children in an attempt to
find new demographics for a declining franchise.
Unsurprisingly, this didn't sit well with adults.
The film is from the perspective of a bullied
child watching poorly cut-together stock fights
taken directly from earlier, better Godzilla
movies. It sold well as a late '60's kid movie,
but it was also a sign of the dark
times ahead for the Godzilla franchise.
Stock monster fights aren't
awful on their own, though,
so no one will blame you for watching
this oddly edited string of them.
With "Ebirah, Horror of the Deep," we're moving
away from the truly disliked films and getting
into "mixed reviews" territory. The main drawback
of this film is how different it is than the more
traditional Godzilla movies — most notably by not
including much of Godzilla at all until the end.
The plot is pretty decent, though: a man loses his
brother at sea, learns from a mystic that he might
still be alive, and heads out on a stolen sailboat
to find him — only to run into a nasty oversized
lobster called Ebirah. Godzilla snoozes
for a while before finally doing his thing,
defeating the crustacean by ripping its
claws off with an assist from Mothra.
The effects and quality hadn't gotten
any better than the earliest films,
but that's one of the things
fans of "Ebirah" like about it.
It's just the major lack of Godzilla
that really drives this movie down.
"Godzilla: Tokyo S.O.S." is a bit confusing.
The plot involves Mothra showing up and telling
everybody they need to get the original
Godzilla's bones out of Mechagodzilla
and lay them to rest because it's disrespectful to
use a dead lizard's bones to raise a new monster.
Then, Godzilla shows up — not the original
Godzilla, who is now inside Mechagodzilla,
but a second, newer Godzilla — and if that's
not weird enough, Mothra ends up helping
Mechagodzilla for some reason instead of going
through with dismantling the mechanical beast.
"Tokyo S.O.S." definitely wasn't as bad
as some of the films that preceded it,
but it's generally considered to be
a lazy attempt by the producers of
the Millennium films to keep up
with the old rate of production.
"Terror of Mechagodzilla" was the last
Godzilla film in what many consider the
tail end of a declining franchise — at
least before its resurrection in 1984.
By this point, Godzilla movies had
largely moved away from horror fare
and into the realm of bizarre creations seemingly
conjured from the mind of a six-year-old.
"Terror of Mechagodzilla" bombed at the
box office, but it has its defenders.
Most of the love for this movie can be traced
to the return of veteran director Ishirō Honda,
the man behind the original 1954
"Godzilla" and several of its sequels.
Honda didn't save the movie entirely, but he did
manage to give it the feel of a Godzilla flick of
decades past. "Terror of Mechagodzilla"
was Honda's final directorial effort
and far from his best contribution to
the franchise, but it was clear that
his passion for the monster had never
faded, even after twenty-one years.
If Rotten Tomatoes' scoring system is to
be trusted, then "Godzilla: Final Wars"
is as mediocre as a movie can be, weighing in at
a perfect 50 percent. It's part of the Millennium
era, in which overarching narrative was largely
abandoned in favor of pure spectacle and bizarre
twists. "Final Wars" was certainly unique,
but that wasn't necessarily a good thing.
The film might be hit or miss, but it
sure is fun. A trove of classic monsters
and aliens descends on the Earth,
leaving Godzilla to save the day.
Classic stylings with modern
effects bring the action to life,
but the acting of the human characters is bad
enough to ruin any suspension of disbelief.
"Godzilla Against Mechagodzilla" is another mostly
unremarkable film from the Millenium era, but it
distinguishes itself by being the first movie in
the franchise in which women are truly essential
to the narrative. Kaiju aren't just for boys,
after all. The film also had a more progressive
and diverse cast of characters, which the
franchise had been trending toward since the '90s.
The Mechagodzilla suit featured in
this film is polarizing among fans:
some think the newer design is a worthy evolution,
while others seem to think that it should've kept
its classic look. Either way you see it, you'll
probably agree the plot is on the weird side:
the old Godzilla is dead, a new Godzilla
has risen to take the former's place,
and now the old Godzilla's bones are
used to create the Mechagodzilla cyborg.
At least it's still easier to follow than
its direct sequel, "Godzilla: Tokyo S.O.S."
"Godzilla vs. Megalon" may not have wowed critics
past or present, but fans certainly seem to prefer
it over most of the films of the Millennium
era. The film is still a "versus" title from
the downturned Shōwa era of the franchise, but
it was better than most at the time, even though
it was being aggressively marketed toward children
in a desperate bid to keep the rubber suit filled.
Although franchise revenues were
continually dwindling at the time,
"Godzilla vs. Megalon" made relatively decent
money at the box office. Much of its success
was thanks to efficient advertising involving
the new character Jet Jaguar, whose design was
the result of a fan contest that Toho held the
previous year. Thankfully, "Godzilla vs. Megalon"
actually feels like a Godzilla film, and for
that, it's earned itself a place at number 25.
In a confusing twist of fate, some
people were actually disappointed
that "Godzilla 2000" wasn't a direct
sequel to the 1998 American version.
For the majority of fans, however, it
was a breath of fresh air in comparison.
"Godzilla 2000" had many of the
stylings of the older films,
giving viewers the version of the King of
Monsters they feared had been lost to the
new world of computer-generated imaging — even
though there's still plenty of bad CGI to behold.
The story is also off: for some reason, "Godzilla
2000" was disconnected from all previous Godzilla
films and raised enough questions about continuity
to leave anyone familiar with the series with a
lingering sense of confusion. All in all,
though, it was a decent movie that blended
modern animatronics with a suit we were pleased to
see hadn't yet made it to the metaphorical trash.
Mechagodzilla has most recently been seen
stopping Godzilla from destroying cities,
but he wasn't always written that
way. In "Godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla,"
the robotic titan's first appearance in
the franchise, Mechagodzilla is a robot
sent by aliens to destroy Japan. Naturally,
it's up to Godzilla proper to save the day.
"Godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla" gave us one of
Godzilla's most iconic foes, and for that, fans
can't thank it enough. We’re also gifted with the
“so bad it’s good” guardian monster King Caesar.
That being said, it wasn't the best movie
it could've been: the film suffers from some
pacing issues and features some truly bizarre
musical choices. It's also gorier than any of
the previous entries in the franchise, which
is a plus for some and a minus for others.
When it comes to "Godzilla vs. SpaceGodzilla,"
most fans have one of two opinions:
Either it's one of the best Godzilla
films they've ever seen, or it's barely
worth watching. If you're into Godzilla because
you like watching big lizards destroy things,
then you'll probably enjoy this movie; after
all, you get two Godzillas for the price of one.
SpaceGodzilla is believed to be a clone of the
original lizard, but with several enhancements:
most notably, those massive crystal spikes growing
out his back. There's some fun tension between
SpaceGodzilla and Godzilla Junior,
too, reminiscent of an abandoned child
taking out his parental qualms on the
sibling who got all the attention.
Outside of that, though, the movie isn't very
good. The psychic subplot continues from the
previous films, but it doesn't have much impact
on anything that actually happens. The special
effects are also lacking, not quite on par
with the other Heisei [HEY-say] era films.
"Godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla II"
scored pretty high with critics,
ending up with an impressive Rotten
Tomatoes score of 83 percent.
Not all fans would agree with that assessment,
however: the website's audience ranking is
hovering just above 70 percent, which feels
more in line with the "fun" factor of this film.
Mechagodzilla is built from the remains
of Mecha-King Ghidorah and, this time,
is meant to be humanity's savior. The movie
also introduces Godzilla Junior — not Minilla,
the baby-faced creature of the past, but
a younger version of Godzilla that grows
up to be half as big, yet just as terrifying. The
only issue fans really seem to have with the film
is with the updated Mechagodzilla design
that lacks some of the classic elements,
such as the iconic finger rockets.
While Mothra is often thrown into Godzilla movies
just because fans like the character, she doesn't
just show up for no reason in "Godzilla and
Mothra: The Battle for Earth." Here, Mothra
takes center stage as the benevolent protector
of Earth. Godzilla rampages, Battra falls from
the sky to teach the world a lesson, and Mothra
joins in the fight to stop Godzilla, eventually
sealing him under the sea. Then, Mothra takes off
to tour the universe for some reason or another.
The effects in this movie are pretty great:
Mothra looks cooler than ever before,
with bigger wings and better coloring. There
really aren't too many negatives about this movie,
but there aren't many highlights, either. It's a
good Godzilla film, but nothing groundbreaking.
The battle between King Kong and
Godzilla, in whatever form it might take,
is probably the most iconic of all the kaiju
fights in the genre. The warm-blooded primate
versus the sea-dwelling reptile is a matchup that
can't be missed. It's so popular, in fact, that a
remake was released in 2021 — and it's also the
reason this movie made it this far on the list.
Unfortunately, 1962's "King Kong vs. Godzilla"
is considered a bit of a blemish on the series
among hardcore fans; not because it wasn't a
good movie, but because it's a symbol of when
Godzilla transitioned from existentially
terrifying to silly and family-friendly.
If you haven't yet seen the modern reboot, you
should definitely pop this in the VCR first
and witness the original battle between
the world's two most beloved monsters.
Critics weren't too pleased with
Godzilla's most recent solo outing,
"Godzilla: King of the Monsters." Many cite the
plot mechanics as "tricky" and hard to follow,
while others claimed the storytelling
was worthless and couldn't be saved.
However, many fans would be quick to disagree.
Sure, the plot and story are sub-optimal, but
the action and spectacular effects drove audience
reviews far into the realm of "favorable." There's
no man in a rubber suit, so it doesn't offer much
in the way of cheesy, classic appeal, but it's
undeniably an entertaining two hours. "Godzilla:
King of the Monsters" features plenty
of our favorite titans, such as Mothra,
Rodan, and the magnificent three-headed menace
King Ghidorah, all looking more lifelike than
ever. It's a testament to the lasting legacy
that Godzilla has cultivated over the years.
"Long live the king."
In an era where the Godzilla franchise
had moved toward younger audiences,
it was rare to see an installment that
pandered to the adult crowd the way the
early, horror-type entries did.
"Godzilla vs. Gigan" was pretty
much the only Godzilla movie from the '70s
that adults could say was made for them.
The film starts out almost like "Jurassic
Park:" a group of business owners want to
summon the world's most fearsome monsters for
their own gain. As you'd assume, this doesn't
work out — but not in the way you'd think. The
businessmen are actually aliens trying to take
over Earth by calling on Gigan and King
Ghidorah to wreak havoc on the world.
The film's highlight is a two-on-two fight with
Godzilla and Anguirus battling the two destroyers.
"Godzilla vs. Gigan" is definitely
worth watching if you have the time,
but like the others up to this point,
it probably won't be your favorite.
One of the aspects of the Godzilla franchise
that made it such a beast over half a century ago
is the social commentary with which it packs its
best films. This started with the original and has
been present on occasion ever since. Often,
those that break this precedent are simply
action for action's sake with no other redeeming
qualities, made solely to entertain and nothing
else. "Godzilla vs. Hedorah," [HEY-dore-ah
or hey-DORE-uh] however, has plenty to say.
The plot revolves around the
pollution that plagues the Earth,
which makes it the perfect target
for the smog-sucking monster to drop
in from space and muck around. Fortunately
for everyone else, Godzilla saves the day,
and the world receives a grim reminder of the
consequences of their less-than-green practices.
The film commonly referred to as "Invasion of
Astro-Monster" has gone by three different names,
depending on date and location. When you see
someone mention "Godzilla vs. Astro-Monster''
or "Godzilla vs. Monster Zero," they're talking
about the same movie. Other than that minor
confusion, which really doesn't factor into
the quality of the feature, it's pretty good.
Since the film is a direct sequel to
"Ghidorah, the Three-Heared Monster,"
the fan-favorite character comes back for a second
helping. The movie is enjoyable, but not quite as
good as the first; either of these Ghidorah movies
could've done without the other since they have
basically the same story. Regardless of whatever
name you call it, "Invasion of Astro-Monster"
is perfectly watchable, even if it doesn't
quite match up to Ghidorah's previous outing.
In order to really appreciate the
Heisei era of the Godzilla franchise
and take in all the fun the '80s
and '90s entries have to offer,
it's best to view them as a similar,
yet separate string of films.
If you do, you'll likely enjoy "Godzilla vs.
Biollante," since it's the epitome of this age.
Some of Godzilla's cells have been recovered from
a volcano, and different groups have different
ideas for what to do with them. Naturally, this
causes a fight, and the cells ultimately land in
the hands of the Japanese military, where they are
spliced with rose DNA and mutate into the creature
known as Biollante. Naturally, you can guess who
Biollante ends up in a big kaiju battle against.
"Godzilla vs. Biollante" has plot,
action, and of course, rubber suits,
making it a darn good film as far
as Godzilla himself is concerned.
As for the acting and character development?
They're far from perfect, to put it kindly.
The first Godzilla movie of the 2020s
is certainly a film worth seeing,
with some of the best special
effects and CGI that money can buy.
Some purists might not enjoy the film's sleek
Hollywood look, but it's undeniable that
"Godzilla vs. Kong" features some of the most
impressive visuals the franchise has to offer.
Unfortunately, the movie falls a little flat
when it comes to character development and drama.
Even though Kong seems to change sizes depending
on what is happening in the film, the exciting
action and visual direction overshadow any
narrative flaws. If you want to see the world's
two most famous kaiju duke it out in stunning
4K resolution, this is the movie to watch.
King Ghidorah makes any Godzilla movie
worth watching, even if said films aren't
cinematic masterpieces — when it comes to
fun, monster-y goodness, King Ghidorah's
three heads are hard to beat. As such, "Godzilla
vs. King Ghidorah" is a delightfully cheesy
B-movie that exists purely to entertain —
especially if you watch the English dub.
"It's a dinosaur! A gigantic
dinosaur is attacking our boys!"
Despite a bizarre time travel storyline, "Godzilla
vs. King Ghidorah" succeeds through delightful
special effects and epic monster designs.
There's two boss fights for the price of one,
as Godzilla's fight against Ghidorah is
followed up with an epic battle against
Mecha-King Ghidorah, an enhanced version of the
monster teleported in from the 23rd century.
This is the perfect Godzilla film for a midnight
movie with a couple friends and lots of popcorn.
Some superfans may see this particular film
as problematic within the Godzilla canon,
but it's an important piece of the franchise's
history. "Son of Godzilla" is the first time we,
well, meet the son of Godzilla. This reptilian
child, a clumsy troublemaker called Minilla,
is a walking embodiment of the lighthearted
humor the series was shifting toward at the time.
In this first appearance, Minilla has to help
Godzilla defeat a giant spider called Kumonga.
Many view the inclusion of Minilla as an even
further push in a childish direction — and
it honestly was — but that doesn't make
"Son of Godzilla'' any less of a classic.
With the franchise having been built on small sets
with big rubber suits from the very beginning,
the classics are what it's all about, after all.
"Destroy All Monsters" is generally considered the
last good Godzilla film before the franchise went
into its '70s slump. The movie is exceedingly
fun, if not chaotic, and packs a heavy punch:
it has the largest brawl out of any Godzilla film,
bringing in eleven of the classic creatures to
duke it out. Not all of these monsters get the
luxury of full screen time, with some only
having short cameos, but that doesn't stop
the film's final battle from feeling like
a tokusatsu version of "Avengers: Endgame."
Viewers have to wade through the
movie's slow start to get to the action,
but every ounce of patience is worth the wait.
It's the last remnant of "the good old days"
going out with a bang. You'll definitely want to
watch this particular film with subtitles, though:
the English dubbing is pretty
awful and hard to follow.
Other than the name being an absolute
mouthful, "Godzilla, Mothra and King Ghidorah:
Giant Monsters All-Out Attack" is an all-around
fantastic film and is easily the best of the
Millennium era. Fortunately, this movie doesn't
feel like an early 21st century garbage heap like
most of the others from the time: instead, we get
the man in the green rubber suit and everything!
Godzilla is back with a vengeance, infused
with the restless spirits of World War II
veterans and ready to destroy Japan in
retaliation for its crimes — that is,
until three powerful guardians come
to the country's aid: Baragon, Mothra,
and King Ghidorah. Even without these fan
favorites on screen, the movie's spirit is
the political commentary of Godzilla's past,
and for that, it weighs in at number nine.
The top ten is highly competitive, and
"Godzilla vs. Destoroyah" is no lightweight:
in fact, it's the only Godzilla movie to score
a perfect 100 percent on Rotten Tomatoes. The
movie was the finale of the Heisei series, and
brought the era to a banging halt. Godzilla was
built up over the course of a decade so he could
meet his end in the final moments of this film.
The finale to the Heisei era was originally
planned to involve Godzilla dueling with the
ghost of the 1954 Godzilla, which definitely
would've been a showdown to remember.
Instead, we got Godzilla having a literal
nuclear meltdown while looking like he
needs the world's largest Tums. That's not
to say the film isn't absolutely fantastic:
it is, and it's definitely worth checking out.
The year was 1984, and the Godzilla franchise had
been sitting near death on a nine-year hiatus.
The goofiness of the Shōwa era
had put a lot of people off,
and if the big guy was going to grace the screen
once more, the film would have to be exceptional.
Sure enough, it was. The nuclear lizard rose from
the sea once again in "The Return of Godzilla."
The first film of the Heisei era brought the
world's favorite kaiju back to its roots. The
plot made heavy commentary on the Cold War
tensions that had been weighing the world
down for years leading up to the film, returning
Godzilla to a mature, less childlike format. Not
everyone was as happy as they should've
been to see the big man back, however;
the franchise had laid dormant for years,
and there were some cynics who believed it
should've stayed that way. Most Godzilla
fans — particularly those in Japan — were
more than happy to see the radioactive menace
make his grand return to the silver screen.
There's no denying "Ghidorah, the Three-Headed
Monster" has flaws when it comes to production
quality, and its stature is more a
product of nostalgia than anything else.
So why is it so high on this list? Well, no other
movie in the franchise introduced King Ghidorah!
The three-headed creature is one of the most
powerful and awesome monsters in the franchise —
not just a city destroyer, but a potentially
world-ending threat — and for that alone,
this movie shines. That's not to say the film
doesn't have other premium qualities, of course.
As opposed to the more human-like
beasts they'd come to expect,
Ghidorah gave fans a truly monstrous
monster. As for the human characters,
they are surprisingly well developed and help
weave humor effortlessly throughout the tension.
"Ghidorah, the Three-Headed Monster" earned its
spot at number six, and it wasn't given lightly.
"Godzilla Raids Again" was the first Godzilla
sequel, released just one year after the original.
It proved to be a stunning film in its own
right, with a ferocity in its choreography
that other kaiju pictures of the day lacked. This
was the first Godzilla film to pit the king of
monsters against another creature of its size:
specifically, the irradiated dinosaur Anguirus.
Ultimately, the spiked creature isn't
powerful enough to take Godzilla down,
leaving it up to the humans
to save the day once again.
For all of its high points, "Godzilla Raids
Again" has its faults when it comes to plot:
most notably, its erasure of Godzilla's
death at the end of the first movie.
Regardless, its importance to the growth of
the franchise truly can't be understated.
Despite what some purists might say,
entertainment is just as important as
historical and intellectual value when it comes to
ranking kaiju movies, and the 2014 "Godzilla" was
just about as entertaining as they come. Nobody
expected an American Godzilla film with advanced
special effects to work — 1998 killed that idea
for us — but this movie showed us that one bad
apple doesn't ruin a bunch of awesome giant
monsters beating the crap out of each other.
The way this movie is shot has
a lot to do with its quality.
Instead of watching monsters rampage in
the distance, the 2014 film gave viewers
a point of view that made us feel we were
right there, looking up at the carnage.
"What are you doing?"
"I have to see this."
The progression withholds details in just the
right amounts, showing us bits and pieces until
we're burdened by the crushing weight of
a sci-fi horror. The movie was masterfully
done in just about every way — we just wish
we could've seen a little more Bryan Cranston.
The best Godzilla movie of the 21st century,
"Shin Godzilla" is not just one of the most
entertaining movies about the giant lizard,
but also a biting piece of political satire.
In this movie, which takes place in an
entirely separate continuity from every
other Godzilla film, not only is Godzilla upset
about being woken up from his decades-long nap,
but he's also punishing Japan in
retaliation for the Fukushima disaster
and humanity's generally
irresponsible use of nuclear power.
The movie spends a lot of time inside bureaucratic
meetings in which the Japanese government tries to
manage the crisis, but that never detracts at all
from the film's power. "Shin Godzilla" embodies
the soul of Godzilla that seemed to have been lost
in the Millennium era's need for mindless action.
Much of "Shin Godzilla's" success can
be attributed to the masterful direction
of Hideaki Anno, the creator of the iconic
anime series "Neon Genesis Evangelion,"
who presents a disturbing version of
Godzilla unlike any other put to screen.
Even though Mothra made her first appearance
in the 1961 film of the same name, "Mothra vs.
Godzilla" marked the first of many times the giant
insect would face the giant lizard in battle.
"Mothra vs. Godzilla" is generally considered the
greatest Godzilla installment from its decade,
not to mention the second
best in the entire series.
Comedic overtones mesh with a serious
storyline to bring us the underdog
fight of a lifetime. Godzilla is
a powerhouse bent on raising hell,
while Mothra is forced to dig deep and use more
strength than ever before to save Japan from his
destructive rampage. It's a classic story of
overcoming evil, but with two giant monsters and
all the cutting-edge effects the early '60s could
muster. The human storyline isn't quite as good,
but that's something Godzilla fans
have come to expect over the years.
You're probably not surprised to see the
first-ever Godzilla movie at the top of the list,
and why would you be? Ishirō Honda's "Godzilla"
is the film that sparked more than 65 years of
sequels, reboots, and series based on the King
of Monsters. Regardless of its follow-ups,
however, the very first "Godzilla" was a
powerful piece raised high on its own merit.
Movie critic Roger Ebert called "Godzilla,"
quote, "the Fahrenheit 9/11 of its time,"
and for good reason. "Godzilla" was created
as a response to American radiation testing in
Pacific waters, as well as the lasting effects
of the nuclear bombs dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki in 1945. The movie was a warning about
nuclear technology in the hands of human beings
and the destructive force that such a power could
have if used incorrectly. Sure, the movie can look
a bit silly at times, as many sci-fi movies from
the '50s do, but its concept is utterly brilliant,
setting a precedent for other Godzilla stories
to speak out about human folly in all its forms.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movie monsters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.